[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with economist at
the eye ian dunt and the deputy
political editor at the spectator katie
balls with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to both of you
so no guesses then uh what the lead
story is for many of newspapers number
10 party gate shame pm and the
chancellor broke the law that is the
headline on the front page of the metro
after boris johnson his wife and rishi
tsunak were fined for attending illegal
downing street parties during lockdown
the financial times says the fines have
pulled more political pressure on both
men and with the police investigation
continuing there could yet be more fines
the i2 reminding us that it may not be
over as far as the fines are concerned
and says 57
of people want mr johnson to resign
the telegraph quotes mr johnson from his
latest apology people have a right to
expect better he has though again
refused to resign
that is also the lead story for the
times johnson refuses to quit they say
the guardian goes with that angle too i
broke my own law but i refuse to go
the mail asks don't they know there's a
war on attacking what it calls the left
howling for resignations when there are
more important things to consider
as the sun puts it i'm sorry but i have
work to do
but the mirror's view is clear the
country is led by liars and law breakers
quick reminder by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out those front pages
while you watch us so let's bring in our
guests once again uh joined by ian dunt
and katie balls welcome to both of you
uh katie what a day um what does this
all mean let's start with the metro
shall we the basic uh
story there the pm and the chancellor
broke the law
yes and this is prime minister defies
calls to quit as um as police find them
for attending bash and lockdown now we
never quite knew when we'd hear about um
certain fines being announced they've
become in batches i think that's been a
frustration to many in government
because there was a drift of nature it
is a second batch of vines and we were
told in advance that the prime minister
received on number 10 would tell us and
i think there was a sense that the prime
minister could get one given that he's
being looked at for several events i
think probably the biggest surprise
today is that rishi student also
received a fine and now this all relates
as did carrie johnson the prime
minister's wife and this all relates in
the terms of this batch of fines and to
an event in downing street those there
insisted it was very brief but it
involved birthday cake singing happy
birthday
and where does it go from here i think
that
if you think about all the various
denials we've had for you know if you go
back to the start of partygate where it
wasn't really a mainstream story to
begin with it was the mirror first
pushing it broadcasters picked up on it
and in the early stages you had repeated
denials from downing street there was
nothing to see there so i think just
take a step back and look at how far the
story has gone we've gone from
suggestions of you know nothing at all
to the fact that the two most senior
members of government have now been
fined by the police and therefore it's a
pretty damning assessment of a the
messaging around this in the beginning
but to what actually went on and down
the street during lockdown and how it
was cultural yes and as you might expect
the mirror is pretty blunt led by liars
and law breakers the statement ian from
boris johnson today
said it did not occur to him that the
gathering in the cabinet room in june
2020 to mark his 56th birthday was a
violation of coronavirus rules but that
he now humbly accepts he did breach
covet 19 laws never mind being a liar
why did it not occur to him
well it did occur to him he's lying
about it now i mean there's no way you
can take any of this stuff
seriously i mean we knew exactly what we
were going through at the time no one
was under any illusions as to how the
rules operated it was the subject of
conversation
every day anytime you were discussing
anything at all no one thought that you
could have a birthday party with your
partner and your work colleagues and
cake whenever you liked nobody thought
that let alone the person that wrote the
law so for him to say it now isn't just
morally abysmal but it's kind of like
it's like a libel against our intellect
you know he's treating us like absolute
fools so even now even when he's banged
to write he still comes out with it just
more lies it's like this endless
conveyor belt of light so certainly he
was never under any illusions as to what
he was doing he just didn't care
well we had it again today and at the
time too when these allegations first
broke that downey street is a unique
environment it's both the prime
minister's office and his home it's a
rabbit warren of rooms everyone's
cheeked by jowl everyone was working
really hard you know does any of this
stack up katie or do we just move on
from those the defense of this and even
the defense of this specific incident
that he was ambushed by a cake
so they've been various defenses i think
that
when we've heard various number 10
figures um often anonymously saying
we're working really hard i think that's
one of the weakest defenses and because
a lot of people during the pandemic felt
like they're working very hard often
alone in really difficult situations and
i think that's one that doesn't garner
much sympathy
i think in terms of the various
incidents um and alleged parties that
the police are looking into
i do think that this instance of the
birthday cake um is probably on a
different level than some of the others
for example you know alleged karaoke
parties people having a disco and that
we can say they all break the rules but
i think certain ones will probably make
uh members of the public more angry than
others and obviously any real breach is
bad but i don't think on the scale i
think this is on the low end which does
beg the question about what's to come
next i think in terms of um what the
prime minister has said um we are
actually seeing an apology today but
if we think about recent weeks when uh
the police first did the first batch of
fines it hasn't been that clear that
number 10 is always apologetic so we've
had various briefings from the prime
minister's spokesperson but they've
suggested that for example you know they
don't necessarily accept the met
police's findings now it seems they do
accept it but i think as ever with boris
johnson there is a sense that
perhaps he is apologetic in some ways
but also you do get the sense from those
around him that they still
are quite frustrated the whole thing has
played out like this and there was quite
a lot of anger towards that police at
the way in which this is being um fed
out in various batches well the daily
mail front page picks up on that uh the
idea that this is the lower end of the
scale of offences if you like boris was
there for nine minutes carry less than
five the birthday cake never left its
tupperware box and last night the pm
rightly apologized as the left howls for
resignations over the mets 50 pound
clovid fines don't they know there's a
war on now it seems like um from that uh
conservative leaning paper he will
survive this ian
i don't know whether he'll survive or
not certainly not because of the mail
what i do know is that that is just the
most grotesque combination of gibbering
lunacies and lack of standards that i've
seen on the front page of a british
newspaper for a very long time the basic
facts of it are that he passed laws that
he then broke when you have to go back
to john locke to try and find the
philosophical arguments for our
societies are based on the idea that the
executive follows the laws that it
passes that's what the rule of law is
all about start talking about how long a
cake was in a tupperware box is to
completely misunderstand what this is
about so it doesn't matter to the people
who weren't able to visit their families
their loved ones that were dying while
they were engaging in this kind of
activity and then as the kind of cherry
on the cake of this abject nonsense to
start using the war in ukraine as some
kind of shield to conceal the moral
culpability of the government here shows
absolutely no respect for what
ukrainians themselves are going to they
deserve better than to be used as
shields in this particular regard and
frankly i mean you have to i'd say i'm
not a big believer in the mail it's had
good moments at certain points that
front page is an absolutely shameful
shoddy shoddy piece of work well the
ukraine war seems to be working for many
including people like sir roger gayle
others who put letters in they say now
is not the time daily telegraph points
out that 14 cabinet ministers offered
public support to the prime minister
including michael gove sanji javid liz
truss
etc etc i mean you know the conservative
party um
in a sense senses the time has passed
katie
i mean i think if you think back to two
months ago had the police announced a
fine two months ago i think would be at
the point of uh counting the number of
letters that we thought were currently
into graham brady the chair of the 1922
chairman so a lot has changed i think
it's one senior tourism earlier today
and the prime minister is now in a much
better place to try and survive this
than he was a few months ago
does that mean all trouble has passed i
don't think so i think that yes the
ukraine crisis the fact there is a war
on has given lots of mps a sense of
perspective it made them wonder if they
should write off a prime minister over a
cake whether it's in a box or out of the
box um but i still think there's plenty
of risk here for the prime minister and
actually the messaging from number 10
has to be pretty careful here because i
think
there is a lot of upset still and if it
looks as though boris johnson and his
team are dismissing the anger that lots
of people feel and because this is still
quite raw for people who gave up things
during that period when number 10 appear
to be doing plenty of things and it
could still come back to fight the prime
minister
okay plenty more on that to come in fact
the the telegraph picks up on that point
too
uh suggesting that whitehall is braced
for the release of the full report into
partygate by sue gray
sources have told the delhi telegraph
that the dossier will be critical of mr
johnson's conduct and will make for
uncomfortable reading for him and a
number of senior white hall figures
we'll certainly talk about more about
that after the break and included
what happens next for rishi sunak after
his difficult week back with that in
just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview joining me once again the
columnist at the eye newspaper ian dunt
and the deputy political editor at the
spectator katie balls welcome back to
both of you um final mention on
partygate katie if you don't mind which
is rishi sunak pictured on the front
page of the guardian one step behind the
prime minister there and also referred
to on the front page of the daily
telegraph with camilla tommeny
suggesting once the government's golden
boy the chancellor could be forgiven for
wondering how on earth he has suddenly
become it's resident sponge absorbing
many of downing street's woes right now
with the headline behind beneath their
lead story after the chancellor's recent
woes this is the icing on the cake now
what happens to him
yes i mean this is a really um
interesting case i think in the sense
that no one really expected uh richie's
unite to receive a fine or at least has
come as a surprise to many in
westminster i think we can include the
chancellor in that
and therefore what happens next now
i think that richard has already had a
torrid few weeks ever since spring
statement his popularity has plummeted
and then we've had questions about his
wife's tax affairs his possession of a
green card early on in his time as
chancellor and i think it's just adding
to the sense that he is no longer seen
as the heir apparent obvious successor
to boris johnson where that changes
things on partygate is i think it's
another reason boris johnson may be safe
with the time being and because the idea
of a tory leadership contest when you're
not quite sure who is going to win or
who the favorite is puts off a lot of
tory mps
and to the story that would probably
have been our lead had it not been for
the news on the fines ian
also on the front page of the daily
telegraph and the times in fact
the us has credible information that
russia may use chemical agents in its
push to take mario paul according to the
u.s secretary of state and this after
the uk said it was looking at claims
that russia had already used chemical
weapons um this is this is clearly a
very serious story still
yeah look i mean the us um intelligence
over this period has been pretty
impeccable uh quite unlike the kind of
intelligence we get from them on the
middle east it's been sound it's been
well ahead of the curve so we start
taking it very seriously we also know
that this is what putin does this is the
kind of thing defended in syria he is a
butcher and a murderer and when things
don't go his way strategically
logistically operationally one of the
things he is liable to do is to descend
into ever greater levels of depravity
and barbarism as he tries to bludgeon
opponents into submission so it all
seems entirely convincing
and of course extremely troubling
ian katie thank you both very much
indeed